so the hulk deadpool and gamora walk
into a bar that's about as far as i got
into this intro netflix is the adam
project from the director who brought
you free guy and some of your favorite
stranger things episodes is a time
travel tale action adventure that will
make you go
adam what so fly with me to the year
2050 as we take a deep dive into the
story explain its time travel mechanics
and puppies if you listen closely the
first song that plays is the 1966 hit
gimme some lovin it's an apt title
because almost every character in the
film is missing love in some form or
another young adam and his mother ellie
have lost their father and husband
respectively and big adam has lost his
wife laura this intro sequence also
introduces us to these two atoms who
coincidentally are both being chased and
beaten up in their respective times ever
since his dad died young adam has been
acting out in school getting into fights
and accruing multiple suspensions it's a
cry for help and puts a strain on his
relationship with his mother i've seen
babies bigger than me i don't understand
you dad would he did not just did you
just say that and i love this line that
his mother says foreshadowing the
arrival of adam's future self you better
start caring because the future is
coming sooner than you think adam's life
turns upside down when a big adam
arrives from the future in the year 2050
time travel is possible via wormhole
technology technology we'll discover was
created by his father lewis reed but big
adam wasn't meant to arrive in the year
2022 he was aiming for 2018 which has
thrown his mission completely off you
see he's searching for his wife laura
shane who jumped to the year 2018 and
was never seen again there's just one
problem big adam's busted time jet won't
allow him to fly until he's recovered
from his injuries that he sustained
while escaping the year 2050. each jet
is coded to the pilot's dna and if it
senses he isn't fit to fly it won't let
him but if you happen to have an exact
copy of someone who shares your dna like
a younger version of yourself for
example it'll allow big adam to repair
the ship and continue on with his
mission the tech is so far advanced big
adam explains that the ship will
actually repair itself but just like the
wound on his body it'll take some time
like many time travel movies the story
does a bit of mental gymnastics when
trying to explain the intricacies of
time travel itself young adam asks big
adam if he remembers any of this
happening when he was a kid he should
shouldn't he but big adam goes through
this complicated explanation which
essentially boils down to this each
person has what's known as their fixed
time the one place where you actually
belong if you stray out of that fixed
time like big adam did your memories
reform and reconcile with one another
it's a convoluted way of saying no big
adam does not remember this happening
big atom has to make sure not to disturb
this time too much because it could
change something in the future he
watches his mother from afar and regrets
how he treated her as a child you know
30 years
you still get sick to your stomach every
time you remember how you treated her
now but why was young adam so mean to
his mother it actually stems from her
mother's misguided belief that she needs
to be strong for her son in the face of
such a tremendous loss the loss of her
husband and father to young adam you
think you're being strong for him
and the problem with acting like you
have it all together is
he believes it but what young adam
really needs to see is his mom being
vulnerable grieving for her husband not
bottling it up and moving on to a new
man when she knows she isn't ready we
know ellie still hasn't gotten over the
death of her husband it's been a year
and a half and she still hasn't taken
out his clothes if she can communicate
her feelings better with her son then
maybe they can repair their relationship
he doesn't hate you
he loves you
well then he knows it's about 33 minutes
into the movie that we meet our villain
maya sorian she's been going back in
time to collude with her younger self in
order to solidify her place in the
future this means buying stocks and
making connections with key players but
going back in time to change the future
is a big no-no and it was adam's wife
laura who found out about saurian's
tampering with time when laura went back
to 2018 saurian planted a bomb in her
jet essentially trapping her in that
time so it's a big surprise to adam when
he's saved by her in the year 2022
because she's been living in that time
for years what was a few days for him
has been four years for her with
sorian's men hot on their tails the crew
knows there is only one solution to make
everything right and save the future
they have to stop time travel entirely
and that can only be done if they go
back in time and stop their father louis
reed from inventing it in the first
place laura essentially holds off
saurian's men while the two atoms take
the now repaired jet back to 2018. and
back in 2018 or what i like to call the
pre-plague days lewis gives a lecture
and says this interesting line physics
is a slog it's a slog we are meant to
work on problems that our children will
solve his son is literally solving the
problems his physics created but when
the two atoms tell their father about
this disastrous future he seems more
invested in the scientific ramifications
of their actions here than the problem
itself you're always more interested in
the universe than you were your own son
big adam holds resentment towards his
father for being an absentee dad but
it's young adam who tells him this isn't
true his dad was there for him coming
home late at night tired from a long day
and still playing catch with him it's
just that big adam finds it easier to be
angry at his dad than sad about him
being gone i think it's easier to be
angry than it is to be sad
and i guess when i get older i forget
that there's a difference this idea of
loneliness also extends to our villain
it's actually what motivates her she
doesn't have any family her company is
her family this company is all you will
ever have it's your family so if time
travel is destroyed it essentially
destroys everything she's worked for and
all that loneliness would have been for
nothing lewis also struggles with being
a father feeling like he's not good
enough his whole life he's had to be the
smartest most capable person in the room
and this extends to him being a father
he feels like he should be perfect in
that too but fails to understand that
his son he doesn't need perfect he just
needs you in order to stop time travel
for good they need the algorithm used to
stabilize the wormholes if they don't
get that then saurian can just build
another particle accelerator the device
used to create these holes and there are
only two copies of this complex
mathematical equation one in lewis's
head and the other in the get ready for
this infinitely shifting plasma
containing algorithm hard drive get that
drive save the world lewis has access to
the accelerator because back in 2018
he's still friends with saurian it's his
machine she's the one who funds it they
retrieve that hard drive but future
saurian has taken a hold of young adam
who i guess they've just left to wait
outside she holds him hostage in
exchange for the drive but when young
adam bumps her her gun goes off and hits
the accelerator essentially starting
this thing's version of a meltdown
anything that's metal gets sucked into
it and i liked how they use this device
for some cool action moves like when
adam bashes this soldier's face in with
his own armor and uses his glove to
slide down the accelerator's side but
the coolest thing that happens here is
the death of saurian she is the gang
held at gunpoint and fires a shot but
because the magnetism is so strong the
bullet curves mid-air and kills her
younger self by killing her younger self
it in effect kills her too and just as
the accelerator explodes they're able to
escape in the nick of time pun intended
on their way back home lewis wonders how
both atoms are still in this timeline if
time travel was destroyed how come
they're still here this is just one of
those things the writers had to concede
if they wanted that heartfelt ending
that's to come apparently it takes a
while for 30 plus years of time travel
to correct itself so it gives our
characters a short time to say goodbye
perhaps the most emotional goodbye is
between big adam and his dad as they
finally get that cathartic moment where
his father gets to tell him he loves him
it's also interesting that lewis doesn't
want to know when or how he dies stating
that no one has the right to change the
future they end up playing a game of
catch the same game big adam remembers
playing with his father as a child but
when lewis comes back after retrieving a
ball the two of them have disappeared
with only slight traces of particles
these are the same color particles that
appear when someone from a different
time is killed but the story doesn't
stop there we see how things have
changed because of the events caused by
the atoms this atom here is likely the
younger young one we saw playing video
games in 2018 and a repeat of a scene
from the beginning plays with some
pretty key differences in the original
adam's kind of a dick hey grab a pile
sorry i gotta get to my room to think
about what i've done call me if you need
me i won't but in the new timeline adam
hasn't been suspended from school and
that fight he got into hey grab a pile
would ya i'll be late for school he even
gives his mother a hug this assumes that
lewis made things right with his son
both ellie and lewis learn to mend their
relationship grieve properly and that
adam is on a new path but what about big
adam he feared that stopping time travel
would result in him never meeting laura
but as luck would have it they still do
i'm lost
not anymore i found him this
conversation is great because of its
double meaning laura is lost because
she's in the wrong classroom but it
works on a deeper level because these
two have been lost from one another it
goes back to what laura said in 2018
that if they do meet again maybe a part
of them will echo in one another even if
we correct the time stream
somewhere in us will be the echo of this
one and whereas the film started on a
love song about wanting love the film
ends on a song about giving love pete
townsend's let my love open the door but
i want to know what you thought about
the atom project was it just another
generic time travel movie or was there
more here i want your thoughts in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram think story yt
until next time remember because if i'm
being perfectly honest with myself you
have a very punchable face